oh hi Harper can you tell mr. president  this is actually a Barefoot Contessa  recipe and took me three and a half  hours to make it cooking my food is like  actually kind of therapeutic oh wait no  I'm doing it last one dude get down mr.  president  Eliot bender just called up a front desk  you wanna come join us on this one okay  is this a trap Elliot it's a work phone  call come on bud let's go okay cuz if  this is the game I don't have health  insurance  hi this is Elliot speaking hey Elliot  get down mr. president  Caitlin it was a trap get down mr.  president  I did it I did it I'm fine what's going  on why are we working good job mr.  president I actually sing Elton John  songs to my lunch after I make them you  can taste the love it face powder  you